hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play dead space okay hopefully the
settings are all configured correctly
now and I'm going to kill some monsters
oh yeah oh oh whoa easy okay okay okay
gimme gimme gimme
what's it um blocked okay I have a
flashlight or something maybe not but
was it hello
everybody shut up they use an event so
are there getting around the ship
okay away food yeah get back I know
you're dead good job good job taking
your own advice
I'm bloody bucks that's a life
ooh but uh I think hello
I think oh hey hey yeah oh I'm a
survivor we ran through all of them on
the way over here okay yeah what the
hell other thing huh keep your voice
down
whatever they are they're not friendly
and half the doors on this ship but
locked because the grind team mm-hmm now
we have to get to the bridge but first
we got to repair the tram system you're
crazy
dammit you're gonna get us all killed
yeah arson to me I'll get you out of
here alive and what's wrong with the
tram a date aboard its ride but there
should be a fair Lavinia was holding the
camera tram blocking the tunnel that
needs to be repaired
who was flown everything is on the other
side of this quarantine we can't reach
it from here now we can but you can i oh
it's on is you guys get to the bridge I
should be able to access the personnel
files you fixed the tram and I'll hope
you find a call okay Oh Nicole is my
girlfriend I'm guessing that simple
message in the beginning okay okay all
right I know you already told me date
aboard needed okay this is a box coming
gimme yeah all yeah coming okay
yeah mark mark yep more coming coming
hahaha controls these controls are like
moving through molasses with a beaver
strapped to your back huh
I'm not good with analogies at least
it's brightly lit um don't where's that
this is you be very okay by me in the
right direction tell me what to do
haha ah get out of here dead out of here
you kick you out of it wait careful
shooting them in the body didn't seem to
work
go for the lift remember them that
should do the job okay whatever you say
cut off limbs to kill quickly dismember
enemies to slow them down okay so go for
the arms and legs gosh what's this
hello credits um why is there money oh
well
okay nothing okay got something
see and stasis looks like that door is
real functioning I look crazy with
Jason's module you just picked up okay
will do ah oh yeah
can I use that on enemies oh whoa hello
you guys were too stupid to use it to
get through that door you just died
what about two losers hello Jamie
ah hello same station pouring no hey kit
I said boring okay um where am I going
okay sounds good to me
whoa
what to help with the help good hell
Fidel I like that that's not fun your
stasis module should be able to help you
with an arm mechanism hello oh cool okay
I know go all right one yes
give it good do it cinnamon get it yeah
Oh honed you hardcore got out of here
gimme give me money
for some reason I've been getting many
get any money I'm getting but yeah eat
you Jim
let him shoot him in the balls oh that's
the most important limb of all gimme
gimme alright is trashed we managed to
get it back to the repair D open now the
right of course nothing's gonna work
nothing on this ship is gonna hurt I
promise you dad I'm all right here's the
beginning nothing nothing is gonna work
and I'm gonna have to fix everything
that's just a wild prediction okay all
right
okay broken
um so fast give it give it give me it
was right there oh okay okay I get it I
get it
going off so smart hahahaha gimme hi hi
got there stop being such a lazy bum
yeah
my noon time okay
why do you have to sound like monsters
coming out the tram is walking the whole
system get the computer online you'll be
able to call them from the control room
ok faster the better
I hear something crawling around out
there I can hear something crawling
around in here so you you just need the
top there - I told you I could told you
I could get dead dead dead jeez don't
say Hammond do I have 9 I have 9 ammo
boots
okay yay
just long enough for a monster to come
get all right going that way but I need
to find out what's Oh what is it what oh
oh oh get get get gone get dead
oh okay hey you okay get no don't don't
even try what the hell was that
okay I just wasted mo that's yeah that's
good that's good Oh why shoot melee
melee melee melee there we go alright
save station gimme gimme gue saving
saving save can I just hit enter alright
gotta use a weird mouse Oh fat Oh
bathrooms are always good Oh apparently
they are ah my mouse stopped working
what long-term romantic ability uh oh
you heard about me and my long-term
romantic ability I don't know ah finally
a bathroom that wasn't completely
horrifying cuz I don't know about you
guys but in almost every horror game
I've ever played the bathroom is like
the worst place to go always something
bad happens in the bathroom
okay this door still yep sure is okay
boink oh not even a problem
not even oh another why these boxes
boink gimme gimme ammo
okay ah hey oh you're fast not fast
enough right in the crotch crotch shot
ah get out of here haha get get no no no
no no oh oh
pwned you your wimpy as hell I was only
like two shots oh what's that
I'll give me your ammo why you have ammo
I have no idea but whatever man
what ever all right
makin progress I'm going the right way
yeah body okay whatever um hello okay
another one box pouring gimme gimme
go hello give me ah oh you're dead man
you're not dead why didn't I jump thank
you
of course
ah inventories full why is it full I
have like no inventory space okay if
obviously if I replace a small medium
med a med pack with a medium one it's
better all right what the hell I gotta
use the arrow keys really what is wrong
with you how do I drop it
enter ah there we go
drop okay now get out and pick up the
meat okay that was tedious get out of
your dead mustard Hey
I was saving there okay
boink boink only for save slots that's
not very fun okay hey there's ammo right
there I see it can I can I get it please
Oh fine I don't need it anyway
Vincent I thought you were dead how many
times are they gonna tell me to cut off
the limbs I understand not stupid I'm an
engineer okay all right who else would
it be
locked there should be a key somewhere
in the maintenance Bay
you don't sound like the other black guy
so I'm gonna guess you're Kendra oh this
looks bad
wait huh hey ho nope nope I shoot him in
the limbs oh good
dead Oh so pwned oh don't even try saw
you coming up ha ha ha
phone [ __ ] pwned pwned ha ha ha ha ha
murdery uh uh ok nothing that high huh
what what hi hi why did I hear it from
the left and you came at me from the
right not fair Oh kizer's was there was
another one get gone gone gone die gimme
gimme
reload I don't like that you have 2x a
min reload just seems counterintuitive
gimme gimme goo ah okay what what do we
got what do we got why lag why lag
what's lag oh are you the reason my
computer was lagging boom Oh bang boom
bang OH
poor monster poor little monster okay
elevator sounds good to me
oh these guys aren't scary not even a
little bit not one the right route of
the elevator up I'm ready for you
I'll trust you Oh can't fool me dead
again
are you Dom bees or something zombies
zombie monsters hello gimmie a Vittori
fall
why is my inventory full already I
barely been playing thee oh my god this
is not not good options okay I don't
need med kits I'm not even getting hurt
but I do need are you son of a [ __ ] you
bastard
I will murder you
there we go okay
alright here boy
doo-doo-doo again I still don't know why
they're giving me money really oh hey no
no no no yeah that's right that's right
oh man it's like it wants the camera to
just zoom into the most uncomfortable
position possible faulty four gyro
faulty 4d scope damaged landing
repulsors damaged four and left 4
viewports I don't know what any of this
means
not at all okay okay moving on hop NoHo
shouldn't put so much distance between
you and I still live not for long okay
that looks precarious these guys are
still dead um God is there a way to
cycle three things on the ground coming
at an annoyance an encumbrance to go
through things oh wow
I don't know I wasn't even watching the
time so I gotta cut it here
thank you guys get out here
Oh boned you hey hey hey hey okay we
done we're done okay thank you guys so
much for watching and as always I will
see you in the next part bye bye